[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
lane kiffin is
joining us on the program the university
of miss mississippi head coach where are
you right now coach
i am in oxford mississippi we are back
at work all right
so this is the this is the official
interview room at ole miss
uh this is actually our team room with
the backdrop
is anything in there that's interesting
uh no just a bunch of chairs
[Laughter]
you're looking lean here you're looking
good you look in shape
thank you good summer yeah got some
discipline this summer
are you all right yeah doing well
um in uh california and
in boca for vacation where i sold my
house
and now we're back at work here uh your
reaction to uh
the new additions coming your way texas
and oklahoma
i think it's great i mean sec is already
most powerful conference and most draft
picks and
and kind of dominating recruiting so
this probably goes to the next level
where you're basically looking at it now
is
you know if you're a recruit especially
with name image likeness money
you want to make that how are you not
going to go to the sec
do you recruit clemson do you recruit
big ten teams what do you what do you
think the sc what else is the sec going
to do
i have no clue um i worry about what i
can control
um obviously don't have any say in that
so i mean i wouldn't
i wouldn't guess that you'd go add more
you know right away
you know kind of like when they put a m
and missouri in
but you never know what would you tell
texas and oklahoma they're in for
joining the sec certainly with football
just every week you know that's the
difference you know coming here
uh when i went to tennessee from usc and
in
alabama and then back here now it's just
every week
you know it's on and you're going to
have some great players on the other
side
and usually some high nfl picks you know
on every team that you play
the name image and likeness has been big
and
i know uh at least it was reported that
you were surprised bryce young at
alabama was
gonna get a million dollars here um how
do you deal with that
day-to-day with your team with players
well yeah i was surprised by that i was
at the sc media days and that was thrown
out there and
i just didn't think that it would get to
that level especially this fast of
players that hadn't started or
really played very much but i guess
after looking at more and
you know talking to people more that
there's more into best investing into
the younger player
that's going to play a few years versus
the guy who's going in this last
year of eligibility that you know if you
sign them you only got them for one year
um you know to make money off of them so
uh it's just a new world that we're
dealing with
um more like it would be in professional
sports we really are professional sports
now
i mean players get paid and we have free
agency
except our free agencies almost year
round so um
you know it really has changed a lot
yeah i was wondering how this works if a
booster at ole miss says hey
i'm going to give this starting
offensive line
50 000 each for whatever promotion
um or a restaurant you know we feed the
uh offensive line at ole miss like do
you do you see those things
happening do you have to put out fires
as the head coach here
or anything go through you with the name
image and likeness
yeah we just send it because it's so
complicated now and
you know what you're able to do or you
can do any of this before you know
it couldn't help out at all so you know
or pay players so now we just
send them to compliance let them figure
it out the uh
the transfer portal how how does it work
that if if a player is going or you're
able to receive a player
how much heads up do you get with that
yeah you don't really you know it's like
i said it's a
free agency without the rules
um so kid just goes in and all of a
sudden he's out there you can go
take him you know or your kid comes and
goes in and
it's not like he can franchise him or
something like that so
and they can like go in and then like
come back so
um it's you know allowing it now that
where everybody can
just go and play immediately is awesome
for the kids but that's a whole
you know i don't think it's going to be
as great as everybody thinks
and you're going to have a ton of kids
just like we have had
hundreds and hundreds of kids that go in
with nowhere to go because the numbers
don't
work right you know you lose these kids
they don't give you new spots
you still only have 25 spots yeah so a
school may only have
one or two spots to take people but yet
all these kids are leaving thinking they
can go somewhere
and then when you take them let's say
somebody took 10
now that's only 15 guys out of high
school you can take so that's
10 less high school players getting
scholarships just to one program
so i i think it's going to have some
unintended consequences here
you had one of my favorite players
elijah moore and he was taken by the
jets what are the jets getting with him
awesome kid i mean i already saw
interviews where they were talking about
it's like he's been in the nfl already
very unique maturity practice habits
preparation so he's a true true example
when they say what a pro player is
he is and already was in college is it
the transition from pros to college or
college to pros
what do you think is uh tougher because
i'm looking at you know what urban meyer
is doing as a coach so is
is there a tougher transfer between
those two
yeah college to pro that's a that's
definitely tougher but they're really
tough either way now
because if you haven't been in one like
even if you go
pro forever and you come back to college
it's just changed so much
and the offenses have changed you know i
kind of
it's like two different sports now you
know the nfl and college
and really it used to be in college we
were always copying the nfl
you know going to make cut ups their
offense and plays
it's actually backwards now nfl actually
over the last
three four years copies college football
if you look at you know the rpos and
different type of throws
and offenses and usage of tempo in
situations
it's actually gone backwards i think
it's harder for a defensive
coordinator you know that's an nfl
background to come in and be successful
in college
well do you think that you got hired you
know with saban at alabama
just because he needed to get caught up
with modern
offenses i mean maybe that's not fair to
coach to say it but
you were brought in to give a freshness
to the offense
yeah and i think that's well documented
you said that you know he wanted to
change
um and credit to him he saw the problems
it was giving him on defense
it actually lost their last two games at
that time
um to auburn and kick six and then to
uh uh oklahoma and sugar bowl
so you know credit to him he wanted to
change and saw that
people that weren't changing and
evolving on offense and still trying to
do the old way
you know pro style under center and all
that they were getting fired
so um you know and
that worked and it changed and then that
to me that changed recruiting of
offensive players at alabama which is
now an issue for all of us because now i
didn't go get all the offensive players
because
it used to be you had a chance to beat
them on offensive or
so conservative well now they're winning
all these awards and everything and
scoring 50 points a game so
now nobody beats them on defensive
players or offensive players
does it feel hopeless at times given how
great alabama is
um a little bit you know at times um
recruiting especially when
he you know announces that his
quarterback his backup
quarterback from last year's getting a
million dollars that's going to be a
little hard to recruit against
i mean we just accidentally threw that
out there you know
[Laughter]
you need to get warren buffett or jeff
bezos to be a sugar daddy for the
program there
yeah we we're gonna need some help on
that one
uh i and i think he's signing a new
contract like how much is saban worth
if if you put a dollar figure on it
each year to that program way more than
what he makes and i understand
you know faculty and when people say
okay how does a
guy like that make that much money when
he just coaches football
but you know the money he brings into
the program and the university
you know people wrote when a football
program's
role in you know the university changed
um you know student applications change
you know so tuition goes up you know
every everything changes
so as crazy as is kids around the
country who watch a football program
doing well and they say i want to go
there even though they don't play
football
well good luck this season coach we'll
be checking in on you and uh always
appreciate your time
all right dan have a good one thank you
thank you that's elaine kiffin
uh ole miss head coach